fans had to wait more than 30 years but
the sequel to 1982 s Blade Runner is
finally here and it's stunning directed
by Denis Villeneuve Blade Runner 2049
pulls all the sleek visuals from the
original and wraps him around a new
storyline set 30 years after the
original following new Blade Runner
officer Kay played by Ryan Gosling who's
tasked with rounding up the remaining
early generation replicants but it's
harder to hunt replicants than it is to
hunt Easter eggs so we took the easy job
and found everything you might have
missed in Blade Runner 20 49 Pale Fire
every time Kay comes out of a stressful
situation he has to perform a post
trauma baseline test it's basically a
mash-up of poetry and gibberish with K
repeating words like cell and
interlinked in response to various
prompts it all seems like nonsense but
the movie left the subtle Easter egg to
help fans decode what was going on there
sort of as it turns out all of those
lines were pulled from Vladimir
Nabokov's novel Pale Fire specifically
this refrain cells interlinked within
cells interlinked within one stem and
dreadfully distinct against the dark at
all white fountain played as for what
that all means it's still anyone's guess
never coughs Pale Fire also happened to
be the book joy picked up in Kay's
apartment enjoy coca-cola the Los
Angeles we see in the first Blade Runner
is awash in the neon glow of corporate
advertisements playing hundreds of feet
high on the sides of skyscrapers how
else would you corner that elusive
flying car demographic but one of the
most prominent ads in the first film is
a display for coca-cola Ridley Scott
explained that the reason he used the
Coke advertisement was that even in a
dystopian world coca-cola is everlasting
well fast-forward 30 even dystopian er
years and apparently coca-cola really is
everlasting even in a world where the
only tree is dead and where people eat
grubs to survive our old friends are
still pumping out sky-high treatises to
enjoy coca-cola by the same token 20 49
also had quick Atari and PanAm
advertisements if you caught them
unfortunately Pan Am went defunct in
1991 and Atari was acquired by Hasbro in
1998 so they're definitely not around in
20 49 at least they'd get to live on
through the power of a
imagination right maybe Sony's hologram
speaking of product placement who would
have had a better reason to advertise
their name than the international
distributor of the whole shebang when
Kay finally tracks down Deckard in Las
Vegas he plugs a coin into a jukebox and
brings a hologram of Frank Sinatra to
life and the name right there on the
front of the machine Sony of course
hey if Pujo can make flying cars in this
universe why can't Sony make Holograms
vintage inspiration Blade Runner 2049
art direction is phenomenal from start
to finish from bleak rainy LA to the
trash heaps of San Diego to the red
tinged Las Vegas smog 20:49 is perfectly
designed to hammer home all the
apocalyptic ruin and that's just the
outside inside the casino where Deckard
lives the set design is even more lavish
but it didn't all come from thin air in
the room where Kay first encounters
Deckard there's a grand piano and at
least a few shots you could even see the
name on it see Bechstein that's cool
kind of if you're into pianos but as one
reddit user noticed the imagery almost
perfectly lines up with a 1920s era Beck
Stein poster everything from the
coloring to the ornate chandelier
hanging over the piano seems to be
inspired by that image if you notice
that now it's the time to go tell your
dad that music history major finally
paid off
original origami you may remember gap as
the pointy moustached Bladerunner who's
always showing up to ruined Deckard's
day in the first film fans were happy to
see that gaff made a quick appearance in
Blade Runner 20 49 when Kay was trying
to track down information about Deckard
with all of 20 seconds of screen time
his cameo in 20 49 doesn't serve to
advance the plot a whole lot but it does
offer up an opportunity for an
on-the-nose Easter Egg just before Kay
leaves gaff lays one of his signature
origami figurines on the table that sure
looks like a sheep know sort of like the
name of the philip k dick novel that
inspired Blade Runner in the first place
of course this little moment also begs
the question if there aren't any trees
left where the heck is gap getting all
this paper was that an engineer in 2012
fans scouring the
Prometheus DVD came across a telling
Easter egg a letter dictated by Peter
Whelan of the alien universe that
supposedly references Eldon Tyrell of
the Bladerunner universe the letter
never mentions Tyrell by name but in it
Whelan calls the man in question his
mentor and says that he's like a god on
top of a pyramid overlooking a city of
angels it goes on to say that this guy's
robotics project literally blew up in
the old man's face of course in Blade
Runner the Tyrell corporation is housed
in a pyramid shaped building in Los
Angeles a city of angels and Terrell's
rogue replicant Roy batty crushed his
skull
so while Waylon may need to tone down
his use of the word literally the
references are all there then back in
May 2017 fans watching the first trailer
for Blade Runner 2049 noticed a figure
that looks a lot like an engineer from
Prometheus launching speculation at the
Tyrell corporation sorry the Wallis
corporation is somehow involved
with the engineers is it all true after
all unfortunately the movie gives no
hint whatsoever but considering the
lengths Ridley Scott is apparently
willing to go to connect these universes
without ever confirming it it's still
reasonable to consider this theory open
to discussion if nothing else it's a
pretty cool Easter Egg right thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]